dallas with the most points scored by a
team this season 56 to 14 is the final
so
that's what we have from here let's
check in with the guys on site jack and
rodney who are joined by a very special
guest hello gentlemen happy holidays wow
okay
a real
a real receiver hey a certified
superstar for being honest
you don't see this kind of just blowout
often in the nfl how good did this one
feel oh it was huge man i think we had
one early on in the season and we kind
of had to talk like it's a great feeling
it don't happen too many times in the
nfl and i just found out that we scored
probably the highest this season so
that's huge did amari cooper's
frustration this week and him speaking
out did that really affect the offense
because it seemed like you guys came out
here with a bunch of firepower not at
all man we understand what we got going
in this room and uh we got guys that can
eat on the outside and obviously we got
guys that we can hand the ball out to so
the list could go on and on it's just
the offense that we had to get going
eventually and uh tonight was a great
night to get it started
everybody's saying the same thing what's
wrong with the dallas offense what's
wrong with this what's wrong with that
rod asked me last time like i don't
think anything's wrong with the dallas
offense what are you guys thinking what
are some of the internal conversations
with all this outside noise going on i
mean we understand uh like everything
that was going wrong for the for us and
uh just able to weekend and we got
connected
obviously he was missing a couple throws
drop balls there was a lot of things
with different individuals and uh just
coming out here and playing our best
just putting up putting it all on tape
and uh
it's gonna be a great time tomorrow hey
bro one of the things that really
impressed me about you everybody talks
about your play-making ability but no
one really talks about your toughness
going across the middle with no
hesitation you're catching balls they're
hitting you low i mean talk to me about
your toughness going across the middle
man
it's tough to be in that slot i tell you
that it's pros and cons for sure and uh
today was one of those days where i was
feeling it no matter what and i you
could tell that was kind of a game plan
going across the middle is going to be
tough there's a lot of bodies going on
and just you got to navigate it man
that's all it is and dak prescott has
been through a whole lot over your time
in dallas how is pairing with prescott
impacted your career it was fairly easy
man just just the the the time he's had
before me and obviously the experience
he's had week in and week out so just
kind of picking his brain my rookie year
made it so easy he kind of assembled the
game down a lot for me uh mentally so
physically i could just go out there and
play fast and you know just make plays
the boy digs man 11 interceptions he
gets another one tonight you go against
him every day in practice i mean what is
it about this dude that keeps the ball
keeps falling right in his hand man he
is a receiver i don't understand what
why people keep trying him on goal balls
beat balls because like at that point
you just playing with fire and uh as you
can see this is the first defensive play
and i saw the ball go up and at that
point he didn't even look at the deep at
the receiver yeah he he is the receiver
so uh just going going against him week
in and week out
day in and day out should i say
all the way from training camp for us to
just go together and then we came in
together so
we understand the pressure that we have
upon us as year two but he's going in
and ready to work
or whatever what's it like for you going
up against diggs on a daily basis he
kills he kills them
all i'mma say is
it's a great matchup it's a great
matchup
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports